- Hey guys,
one of the great things about DailyVee
is that Drock's around a whole lot
and some things are obviously
gonna be for the show
but sometimes things come along
that can stand alone.
And what you're about to watch
is something that I know will bring value
to so, so many of you.
It's a long clip
but it's advice that 65%
of my audience really needs
and I hope you enjoy it.
How old are you?
- 32.
- Perfect.
You're at the point now
where why don't you just
take three years and just do
and see what that tastes like.
'Cause you know what filling
journals tastes like.
'Cause I think one of the
things that really works for me
is I'm not worried about the micro,
but I think about the macro.
Oh, I don't know where the
fuck this just came from
but I just walked in and saw it.
This helps me a lot.
Like what the fuck am I
doing with you right now?
This has a lot more to do with
the showing up to the funeral
than it has to do with
fucking the bank account.
And you know what's funny
is if you actually live
your life like the funeral,
you end up making stuff for
the bank account by accident.
You end up meeting somebody who, you know?
It's so crazy when I think about
like how I invested in Twitter
and made all that money.
It was more about giving
a shit about my funeral,
like doing the right
thing by a bunch of people
which led to going to South by Southwest
which led to me meeting the Twitter guys.
- Yeah, like following your passion,
following your bliss.
- Yeah, I mean you just got to
really think about like how,
I'll tell you,
like even in four seconds,
maybe some of the context Robert gave me
I may be making some assumptions
but when you're thoughtful,
I think one of the things
that people struggle with
is actually being very
real with themselves.
- What do you mean?
- The difference between
understanding who you are
versus who you wish you were.
And I think that's
something that I'm always
very fascinated by when I
have a meeting like this.
Like what kind of read
do you have on yourself?
I think I would struggle a lot
if I didn't really
genuinely know who I was.
And then once you know who you are,
you get more comfortable
with what you're up to.
So like if I asked you right now,
and I think it ebbs and
flows when you're 28,
when you're 32, when you're 57,
if I asked you right this second,
what do you want to happen,
what would you say?
- [Male] What do I want to happen
with my creative projects
or just with life?
- Sure.
- All of it, all of it.
Uh, what do I want to happen?
I want to have a life
where I'm able to create
with fun, create with a team.
I want to put out content
that affects people's lives
for the better
in terms of helping them feel good
or better about themselves
and their relationships
and cultivating relationships
that are meaningful.
I want to travel with my band
and have international property
and travel for fun and also for play
and also a little bit of time for work.
But controlling and
delivering like with ease
and also impacting people for
the better in the process.
- That's cool.
What are you hoping,
as you're rolling up to this office
what are you hoping for?
For real, by the way?
- [Male] Yeah, for real, for real.
I mean there are like you
know shit that I do not know.
So I honestly just want to pick your brain
about a couple of key things.
And really like ideally
what I was hoping and what I expect
is like to get in a place
where I know you and I could-
- Hit me up?
Start the process of
building a relationship.
- [Male] Right.
- Okay, let's start with this,
if you want to,
listening to what you said,
the first thing I will tell you,
the best thing, I think, I hope,
I think the first best
thing I can tell you
is don't front.
The number one mistake
that people that aspire to the sentences
that you just spit out of your mouth,
the number one mistake they make,
is they try to oversell themselves
because they think they need it
to have people's attention.
- [Male] Try to oversell themselves?
- Correct, so let me give you an example.
Whether it's life coach,
inspirational figure,
business coach, whatever form it takes,
I think it's much smarter
for you to talk to the world
about your process of going through this,
than the advice that you think
you should be giving them.
And that's where people are struggling.
I got real lucky.
I've never said this, Drock,
so place real close fucking attention,
I'm not sure that if
the internet was around
in its current form
that I would be as successful,
because at 22 and 23,
I knew I was special
and I might've not been patient enough
to first build a business,
first get experience,
I didn't start talking to
the world till I was 35.
And I love to say to you be patient,
to you to be patient,
I'm not sure if I would've been.
I'd like to think I would've been,
but the freedom of putting,
I love to hear myself talk.
And I think anybody that aspires,
think about, so do you,
and so do so many of you,
like that's what it is.
And it's nice.
There's nothing wrong with that.
It sounds bad.
It's funny, a lot of what I deal with now
is being okay with not
being politically correct,
work/life balance,
cursing, whatever, meritocracy.
I don't know if you've seen this,
did you see that I was
on The Breakfast Club?
- [Male] Mmhmm.
- So I don't know if you
watched that interview
or some of the content
that I've been building on,
I'm on a hot no excuses kick.
I have a lot of female entrepreneurs,
I have a lot of fans that
are African Americans,
I spent a lot of time in that community
in my college years,
I just think I'm giving the best advice
to women and minorities in business today,
which is tough.
And it's crazy,
like you have to understand,
in my body right now,
it doesn't feel great,
it feels a lot better
going somewhere else.
The problem is it's the truth.
Like the market just doesn't care.
And what's cool is when
you actually say fuck it,
then you start betting on your strengths.
Do you know I was a business man
in a world where going to smart colleges
was the only thing that
mattered for business men?
You were only a good business man
if you went to Harvard Business School.
And then I reversed it.
I'm like I'm a D and F student.
I curse, I don't dress the part, I do me
and then you know what happened?
The world came to me.
And so I would tell you
that the best thing that you're
gonna walk out of here with
is something that took me a
long time to really realize
is if you want to pull this off
and you want people listening to you,
there's only one thing, the truth.
- [Male] Just more of
your authentic voice.
- The fucking, and everybody
says that fucking cliche term
- [Male] Just be yourself
and all that shit?
- It's unbelievable how much
that's the reason I'm winning.
And I think it's easier
when you have a level of success
and it's harder when you're
climbing up the ladder
but I think that there's a lot of people
who if they talked about
the journey of the climb,
could win.
I think it's the best piece of advice
I can give right now
to a bunch of 20 to 30 year olds
that feel that they should
be talking to the world
and bringing value.
Talk about your journey
of trying to find that voice
and synthesize it properly
versus let me tell you,
because the problem is
a 30, 40, 50 year old,
listening to your one minute
rant video on Instagram,
even if it's powerful,
there's a level of cynicism of like
but what do you know?
- [Male] Yeah.
- And I think that that's fair
and look, you could just be
a whiz kid about the world
and that exists,
but I do think there's a
smarter way to context it.
It's like starting the
sentence of you should versus,
you know it's funny,
right now I can say you should
'cause I've built so much.
But if I was at 20 and needed to be like
my intuition says,
and that changes everything.
Or when I look at,
or when I met with Gary
today the takeaway I got was,
got it?
- [Male] Yeah, what your perspective is
on cultivating relationships
with people who not only
believe in your ideas
but can actually help fund
or will point you to funds?
'Cause right now all of my friends
are broke and trying to create some shit.
I can't borrow from your
negative bank account.
So how do you get into a position
where you are around
people who are influencers
or who also will donate or
whatever the case may be?
- The market will give you money,
whether it's Kickstarter,
I'll give you money,
you just have to give somebody
what you want it against.
So the biggest problem right now is,
finding money's not the
problem, really, it's not,
I'll explain.
- That's definitely my problem right now.
- Well let me explain, it's not,
it's how you're looking at the world.
There's things like
AngelList and Kickstarter,
do you know how much harder
it was for your mother
to get money?
- [Male] Oh yeah, yeah,
I remember that shit.
Yeah I remember.
- Do you know how hard
somebody would slap you,
do you know that the 1973 version of you
if he was sitting here
would punch you in your fucking mouth?
Because money is the last
thing you have to worry about.
AngelList, Kickstarter,
the world can give it to you,
you start a Kickstarter, you can.
You know why most of 'em fail?
'Cause most shit is whack,
'cause most stuff isn't good,
'cause most people don't give a fuck.
You can go to AngelList and
hit up all the angel investors.
The real question is before you go there,
is I think most people say,
everybody says to me
Gary I can't find money
and then I go, cool, I'll give you money,
what do you got?
And then they don't know.
So what am I buying, your brand,
what, in perpetuity?
Got it?
We're living through a
really interesting time
in the world right now where people don't,
where art and science and
business are colliding,
and they're all very different.
I understand the art that's in your heart,
but how you gonna,
yeah, see I got lucky,
I had the art and the business.
But like okay, what am I buying?
Buying into Gary Vaynerchuk
would've been a really good
idea for a lot of people
but that wasn't for sale
and I don't even know how to sell that.
Like what do you sell?
What are you gonna make
20% of my speaking fees
or my book deal or my TV deal
I just signed, like right?
I guess you could do that.
I actually do think that
plays out over time.
But if I said to you, cool,
I got money for you,
what are you selling me?
What's the business?
- So what I hear in that
is when you show up with more content
that allows people to see more
of what they're investing in?
- No, what I would say
is what's the container
I'm putting my money in?
You could have unlimited content,
you could have 4,000 episodes of a podcast
and the greatest Instagram
account I've ever seen
and the funniest Snapchat
and Instagram stories
I've ever seen, great.
- So that's not inherently
letting people know what
they're investing in?
- That let's them know
a little bit about you
but what's the vessel?
Got it?
So when I meet Fuck Jerry,
or when I meet the Fat Jewish,
I know they've got attention
on Instagram three years ago
that really matters,
what am I investing in?
Oh, Fat Jewish, you're making a rose?
Oh, I can put $25,000 into that
and own eight percent?
Now you've given me something
to put the container in.
Oh Fuck Jerry, you want
to become BuzzFeed?
You're gonna build a website
and have traffic and sell ads?
You got to come to me and say
what am I investing in?
You have to put your thing
into a container that's investable.
Nobody's writing a check to a person.
- [Male] Yeah, okay package it.
- Package it.
And then it gets hard
because once you package it,
you have to be able to
explain it in business terms.
And that's not necessarily
what everybody does.
This is where it gets into partnerships.
One thing I would tell you,
based on the vibe I'm picking up,
if you and I both grew up in Milwaukee,
I would've been a great partner for you
because I could've been the
business man to the art,
if that's how you're thinking about it.
Maybe you're the business part,
but it's not what you've
been bringing up yet.
- [Male] I don't know,
I've been in a position
where I've had to do like
both right now, you know?
- Well look, I mean,
you should be putting out content
on a very regular basis.
You should start a pillar show,
whether it's, I mean vlogging
I think is very fascinating.
You should be doing Instagram stories
and Snapchat stories at scale.
You should be putting out
seven to 25 pieces of content
on both those platforms a day.
- [Male] A day?
- And let me explain how.
Don't go fancy.
Document versus create.
- [Male] Oh shit.
- You like that, right?
It's a big shift.
When I say seven to 25,
you say, my God,
how do I produce seven
to 25 meaningful things
that will have me
respected versus document?
- [Male] See that's
always the thing is like
meaningful that will get me respected.
I feel like everybody can put out shit.
And I don't want to put out shit.
- But shit is subjective, my man.
And I got good news for you,
you're fully in control.
- Yeah, yeah.
- People are always like Gary,
like I'm in control.
You know how many things I say no?
They send me quotes to
put on an Instagram, nope.
I'm in control.
Who makes the final call
on like productions,
the producer, the director?
I don't know, whoever,
who's the final person?
- [Drock] Producer.
- Great, you're the
producer, my man, right?
I don't know, you take a selfie
with a nice skyline and eh,
but you got to put out stuff.
And you got to fabricate it.
Like I still can't believe how many people
that live in New York,
don't use New York people.
If I were you and I had an hour right now,
go in the fucking park right now,
like I don't know, go back
to your basketball roots,
stand outside the garden
right there and be like,
what do you think about
the Knicks upcoming season?
Interview four people,
once person gets into a
thoughtful conversation,
he was the former ball boy in 1957,
it's a nice story and boom,
you see where I'm going?
People aren't starting.
- [Male] People aren't starting.
- They're just not making.
They're thinking, they're pondering,
they're strategizing, they're debating.
The difference between people like me
and the far majority
is I'm just doing at all times.
I'm doing so much
that I've decided to have a fucking man
walk around with a camera and follow me,
'cause who knows when it's gonna happen.
And you know what's so funny?
In parallel in my brain right now,
when you leave here, I'm gonna say to him,
Drock, I want this whole
thing cut, the whole thing.
Like what I'm giving you,
so many need right now,
so I'm like fuck it, let's
just put it out, right?
- [Male] Right.
So like you mentioned before,
you have to be putting
out content all the time.
I personally go through these periods
of extreme creativity
and extreme just chill,
like I'm not feeling it.
How do you motivate yourself
or how do you continue this process
of like go, go, go, go, go
and balance that with like self care
and checking in with yourself?
- I do what feels right to me.
- [Male] You do what feels right to you?
- Yeah.
So if I got to check out for the weekend,
I check out for the weekends all the time,
no creations, people are
like, where's your Snapchats?
Like I don't know, got
to be with my family.
I don't punish myself.
- [Male] That's really
hard for me right now
because I feel that same thing of like
dude, you're not putting shit out,
you're not doing enough.
You have the following
and you're not doing shit.
- I agree.
- [Male] All right, Gary.
- You see where I'm going?
- [Male] Yeah.
- I don't know, life.
I don't think you should
squander it but like,
listen, this is back
to do you know yourself
or do you aspire to be something
you might actually not be?
This is the toughest
question of it all, my man.
I mean if you want to be
respected and really known-
- [Male] Show up.
- Show the fuck up.
Are you fucking kidding me
with going a week without doing something?
I don't know how much
into my content you are
but I always say nobody you've ever met
got there without the hard work.
Nobody you know,
it's just real.
Do you know how insane the
DailyVee and the Snapchat stories
has been to everybody?
They didn't realize how
hard I was going at it.
You can't believe how many,
you can't believe how many people have,
you know how many people
used to say the word luck,
that word luck has gone right back,
nobody has the audacity
to say that to my face now
and I love it.
And that's why I did it.
I made it for you
because you can watch
it and be like, okay.
But I think yours is different
and I think a lot of theirs is different.
It's because I'm not fancy about it.
Document over create.
I mean there's so much magic going on.
Dude, you're in fucking New York City.
You know how many people,
again, I'm gonna cut this whole thing
'cause this is the advice everybody needs,
you know how many of them
sitting in a place
that's not New York City?
You got a billion fucking
stories out there.
You don't feel motivated
that you need to tell a
story today or create?
Go let somebody else to do it.
You have so much charisma.
You walked in here in two seconds,
you walked in here in two seconds
and I'm like okay, this kids got a little,
like you can roll up on anybody
and get them to feel comfortable,
except racists.
(laughing)
- [Male] I do that shit every day,
I could do that too.
- But do you know what I mean?
That's so fucking awesome.
So you can't create?
Distribute.
Got it?
You can't create today?
Facilitate.
Yeah man, there's no excuse
for not talking to the world.
It just doesn't have to be
your thoughts and words every time.
- [Male] Yeah, thanks for that.
- I'm on fire right now,
I'm on fire, Drock.
- [Male] Do you have
like a few more minutes?
- Yeah, I mean look,
I'm going until they pull me out.
You're already eight minutes over,
so you're winning.
- [Male] Building a team-
- Don't even think about,
you're not even close to that.
- [Male] Why not, what do you mean?
- You don't have the money
to really build the team.
You can have homies help
you out along the way.
Truth is-
- [Male] I feel like I've
exhausted those resources though.
- Good, let me give
you a real good answer,
I got a feel for you right now.
You need to work on you
before you worry about a team.
- [Male] What do you mean?
- I mean you got to
get your shit together.
Like you're responding
to the right things,
I don't know much,
what I do well is I talk
and then through reaction I listen.
That's how I get a lot done
in a meeting like this, right?
I can tell that you've got certain things
that you need to do,
before you worry about a team,
get your thing in place.
- [Male] Consistency first.
- Yeah, get great at what
we just talked about.
If I go look now,
and I'm gonna check,
now I'm curious,
if I go look in a couple weeks,
and I'm like oh my God,
six Instagram stories per day,
fucking four Instagram posts,
he's been on Twitter
on point, his Facebook,
oh he's got a YouTube channel now,
like create, distribute,
do all that stuff, interview.
There's so much creative shit, man.
Like I'm way more creative than I realized
because stuff comes so natural to me.
Like for example,
like do a meme, and that's
just a slang term for it,
go take a picture on every
odd street in New York,
like Manhattan, like I don't know,
like go start at 113 and then 111 and 109,
anything could be, like right?
Like call it Odd Corner
and just literally do an interview
everyday on Instagram for a minute
starting at 113th all the way down,
that's cool, right?
And like I'm just making shit up,
like I don't know.
Odd Corner, #oddcorner,
just show every fucking Monday,
you go to fucking 113th,
then next week, 111th
and literally you stand there
until somebody walks by
and you interview that person
and that's the fucking show.
I think what I'm good at
is building a pillar up top
that creates content below.
DailyVee, AskGaryVee Show, right?
And then it all flows from there.
Where did this quote come from?
I don't know.
Somewhere along the way.
That's what's powerful.
And I think you need to create,
I think one thing that
people struggle with
is they think it needs to come from them,
and it needs to come
from the structure down
instead of, got it?
And that's why you wake up
and you're like damn, I'm not,
you know how hard it is
to manifest that kind of
original creative thing
from the bottom?
But if you literally lived
your life under show,
think of yourself as like CNN or MSNBC,
Monday is Odd Corner, that's it.
If you white boarded now on
mini shows that you could do,
Monday's Odd Corner,
Tuesday's like subway shots,
Wednesday's like suburbs,
you're just literally going out.
And all of a sudden,
suburbs clicks and all of a sudden,
Toyota's hitting you up and saying,
hey, we'll pay you and
you'll drive a Toyota
to Jersey, to Long Island,
you see where I'm going?
- [Male] Mmhmm.
- But you got to put
yourself in that position.
But what you then are able to do
is you don't have to think.
You know why podcasts have
worked for a lot of people?
Because they interview people.
So they don't have to do the work.
That's right.
That's why when everybody's like,
oh I love this podcast, oh Gary Vee,
and I'm like, you don't get it,
they're just interviewing people,
I'm creating original from the get.
My version of that was
what's a better version of that?
Oh, answer people's questions.
Also, scalable but brings
value to those individuals
and the entire community.
Got it?
- [Male] Got it.
- Good man, give me an update in 30 days,
send me an email.
I'm dead serious.
This is, you came in here and said,
I'd like to start the
process of a relationship,
ideas are shit,
execution's the game, right?
Email me in 30,
either you're gonna email
me in 30 days and say,
look what I did
or what you're gonna do is not email me.
- I'm gonna throw you an email.
All right, thanks man.
- You got it, brother.
- Appreciate you.
- Take care.
For those that have
gone through this video,
I would really love a detailed comment
on the number one
takeaway from this video.
There's something here
that I really want to
continue to expand on
that I think is gonna really bring value
and help people that
are in a rut really win.
So please in depth
comment on the one thing
that you really took away from this video.